LAURA LING: It's Saturday night
here in Mukuranga, Tanzania.
And we are hanging
with the locals
here at the movie theater.
I just bought my ticket.
It was 500 shillings,
which is about $0.50.
So let's go inside and
see what blockbuster
they're playing tonight.
They're playing a
local Tanzanian movie.
It's called "GENGE."
How's the movie?
You like it?
SUBJECT 1: Yeah, very good.
LAURA LING: Most people in this
town don't have electricity,
so they come here
for entertainment.
Luckily, this place
has a generator.
What movies are popular here?
SUBJECT 2: At this theater we
watch most Bollywood movies,
American movies, like Arnold
Schwarzenegger, Rambo.
But also we play
video games here,
because they don't have
power and TV at their homes.
LAURA LING: Ah.
So they come here-- people
will come here and pay
to play video games.
SUBJECT 2: Exactly.
LAURA LING: Wow.
So it's just like anywhere
else in the world, movies
and video games are popular.
SUBJECT 2: That's right, yeah.
LAURA LING: Please check
out this next video.
It's getting dark out, and
this facility has no power.
Racho is about to
see a client, who
could give birth at any moment.
So Racho, basically,
has to do whatever
she can just to make it work.
To learn more about energy
poverty visit ONE.org/energy.
Thanks for watching, and be sure
to subscribe to Seeker Stories.